hi I'm Erik Bosse and spider-man knew
that the spider-verse is now available
in digital HD making it easier for those
of us who are obsessed with finding
little visual details and movies to spot
all the little reasons why this movie
won the Oscar for Best Animated Film and
should have probably been nominated a
woman for Best Picture right
hashtag Oscars so boring I already made
a video that broke down a ton of the
Easter eggs that you might have missed
but now that the digital version is out
I realized there are even more
fascinating visual details that the
animators snuck in so lets rewatch into
the spider-verse see my scene to find
anything else we missed let's get
started okay the opening montage shows
the Peter Parker of the 1610 universe
voiced by Chris Pine catching us up on
his backstory now in the other video I
pointed out the mini Spidey Easter eggs
here but listen to this Uncle Ben moment
great power comes great responsibility
producer Phil Lord confirmed that they
actually reused the audio from actor
Cliff Robertson from the first Sam Raimi
spider-man movie with great power comes
great responsibility
great power comes great responsibility
this is kind of like how they reused the
late Marlon Brando's voices jor-el for
Man of Steel next is just a little fun
thing that I noticed as miles sings post
Malone sunflower in his room he taps the
marker and is that example so he can try
to hit that high note of the song and
the animators include his little impact
lines also notice miles groins one of
them is leopard on from the Japanese
spider-man TV series and as Myles heads
out to school he passes his height
markings on the wall and as he squeezes
past his mom he jumps up a little bit
that's just a small thing but it does
set up the recurring visual gag of miles
height throughout the movie like how it
suddenly shoots up after he gets bitten
in the deeper thematic arc of him
learning to stand tall to be worthy of
the spider-man identity as his dad
drives him to school miles sees a news
report and at the bottom of the TV
screen there's a newsreel headline
Bitcoin hits new high with intro to
futures market this actually gets a call
back later during the report of Peters
death Bitcoin gets new high pitt coin
hits new low but also on that earlier
news reel I love this other headline
largest baby born today I wonder if this
could be a nod to kingpin he does kind
of look like a giant baby and his whole
evil plot essentially gets born on this
day later in school miles teacher hands
back his test paper which miles
intentionally bombed to try to get
expelled
but notice how they also wrote a made-up
month December Airy trying to get that
wrong too I guess
now this could be a nod to the months
that spider-verse got released
theatrically in December 2018 digital in
February 2019 and who knows it is an
alternate universe maybe they have
alternate months like December Airy or
smart lousy December Airy weather but
next is one of my favorite details and I
thought I saw this before I wasn't sure
though on Uncle Aaron's TV is miles
visits as an episode of community in
which troy donald glover wakes up in
spider-man PJs Glover has always been
connected to spider-man he voiced Miles
Morales in the ultimate animated series
and he actually played uncle Aaron in
the live-action Marvel Cinematic
Universe and at this time one community
was out there was a big push to reboot
the live-action spider-man with Glover
as Myles
unfortunately now he's probably a bit
too old but it doesn't matter he's a
global superstar making music videos and
winning Grammys and selling out Madison
Square Garden as they work on the no
expectations wall art the alchemax
spider creeps up on miles and notice how
it blends in with the spray paint color
surfaces this foreshadows the cloaking
ability that's among miles new powers
after the spider bites him and later
when miles scrolls through his contacts
actually pointed out the past video the
mini cameos among the names thinnest one
Jason Reynolds of the Mouse Morales why
a novel and when Fisk's Collider
explodes we see this wide shot of New
York as a shock wave knocks out the
lights now we come back to this shot
every time we meet a new Spider person
but if you look closely you could see
the five of these new spider things
blasting out of the explosion scattering
throughout the city and just another
little detail I appreciated when Wilson
Fisk slams down on Peter to kill him he
roars with rage and the animators stuck
in some drool from his mouth that flies
out now I also mentioned before that
post Malone an addition do sing miles
favorite songs sunflower he also makes a
cameo somewhere in this movie and we
found out where when the bystanders are
marveling at the glitchy
interdimensional mess on the sidewalk
post Malone voices this art snub yeah I
think it's a Banksy and as the world
learns about Peter's death miles visits
the spider-man memorabilia shop where
the late Stan Lee makes its cameo but
actually if you pay close enough
attention during this rewatch you ruin
your vision as much as I have family
shows up all over this movie he pops up
for one frame on the subway train scene
transition he's one of the pedestrians
who steps over miles and Peter B Parker
on the crosswalk in the final seconds of
the movie he shows up for
one super miserable frame saluting miles
with the famous spider-man webslinger
pose as he passes him on the train
Stanley in a way is kind of a guardian
angel for miles and I'll point out later
how this moment was stand in the merge
shop actually plays a major role in the
final act moving on when miles meets
Peter B Parker Peters recap includes a
shot of him getting hit by this bus if
you look closely you can see that the
driver of that bus was a villain
tombstone who ends up being one of
kingpins henchmen in this universe - in
the alchemax lab I pointed out in the
first breakdown that Olivia's reveal as
the Doc Ock of this universe was
foreshadowed by the recurring number 8
imagery like the octagonal glasses she
wears the octagonal furniture but
another detail I found interesting about
her is this notice how she introduces
herself my friends actually call me
Liv's leader in the movie when Olivia
arrives in Aunt May's home notice what
Aunt May says oh great it's Liv
so does this mean it may and Olivia were
friends it could be kind of a nod to the
fact that in the 70s spider-man comics
Doc Ock and Aunt May actually had a
relationship got married was weird but
since this Aunt May's seems pretty
involved in Peters tech maybe she used
to work with the Lybia like an R&D or an
engineering maybe a kind of mentor
figure one of my favorite details that I
spotted in the first breakdown when
Miles stores a bagel at one of the
pursuing alchemax scientists when it
hits him in the head it makes the action
word bagel but listen to it again they
also slipped in this awesome sound of
thing I guess bagels do have a lot of
gluten fighter Gwen recaps her backstory
and we see the moment she lands in Times
Square
now I already pointed out most of the
sign billboard Easter eggs but this
angle shows us another back rub back rub
was the original name for Google and
that's why it's in Google's multicolored
font you can also see Picabo which I
pointed out before is this universal
snapchat but I realized that snapchats
original name was actually Picabo also
in Times Square
later spider-man noir sees a sign for an
e a water polo game now they meet up
with Aunt May and head down into the lab
and yeah there's a lot of stuff in here
that I pointed out but one new detail
Peter's weight bench so many weights
that's probably a joke about Peter B
Parker's comparatively slouchy figure
but notice how the weights say Marvel on
them could also be a joke about how all
the Marvel Cinematic Universe heroes
have to get ridiculously jacked
to play the roles and of course there's
a ton of different spider-man suits on
display I ran through them before
but one that I missed is the electro
suit that's to the left of the main suit
that miles looks at now jumping ahead to
win all the spider people into fighting
Fisk in his goons as a Collider goes
haywire there's a few interesting new
details that I spotted here one of the
alternate dimension set pieces that
floats through the particle stream is
this thing this is from the movie Cloudy
with a Chance of Meatballs it's the food
weather machine that Flint builds or for
short Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs
was of course another animated feature
from producers the Lord and Chris Miller
and actually brought that movie's VFX
supervisor Danny Damian and art director
Michael Corinne ski who played these
roles on spider-verse - this whole
chaotic finale feels like something
directly out of Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs also notice when Spiderman
more fights tombstone all of his action
words or old-timey expressions like
applesauce and in the showdown with
miles and kingpin I put it out before
how there appeared to be some daredevil
imagery as a nod to kingpins role as the
villain to daredevil in addition to
spider-man he's in New York villain but
when the Train thereon passes through
the particle stream Fisk sees his wife
and son again alive in these alternate
dimensions that they're flying through
and he could see lots of interesting
variants flashed through including
Vanessa and Richard having grown older
and ones in which their different races
and one of the flashes of this train
include Japanese Kanji lettering on the
wall suggesting that these could be
bisques family and Penny Parker's
universe but most interestingly one
version shows his son dressed up as Matt
Murdock with the suit in the sunglasses
so maybe this could be a hint to Fisk's
complicated relationship with Murdock
seeing him as a son figure but I want to
jump back to that shot of Miles as he
gazes at the spider-man suit in the lab
notice how his reflection lines up to
make him look like he's too short to
fill in that suit because in this scene
we learned he's not yet ready to become
spider-man but later when he returns to
this lab having changed his reflection
now lines up perfectly in the mask as
he's ready to bear this responsibility
this victorious moment was foreshadowed
by Stanley himself earlier with the
seemingly throwaway joke you know always
eventually but this Gordian Ames was
exactly right and they emphasized this
transition from humiliating defeat -
proud victory for miles all of his big
power moves in the final act of the film
our restaged versions of moves that he
learned throughout his journey like
noticed I was leap of faith off the
skyscraper is now inverted to look like
he's rising and he's able to let go with
the glass despite his past anxiety would
force him to stick to things now he's
totally relaxed he's got some flour
playing in his head on repeat and now he
swings up with the cheer whoo following
him up compared to the scream aah
following him down and this fall earlier
rather than smack him into the pole he
now uses a pole to propel himself up and
this parallel victory lap continues in
the collider sequence he swings in sync
with Peter once again just like they did
earlier in the trees and approved to
Peter that he's got this smile sweeps
the leg and grabs him by the chest
perfectly replicating Peters move on him
earlier and when he goes off to face
kingpin alone his moves are an exact
callback to the badass bravery that he
saw from the first spider-man of this
universe the one who died he clings to
the rising turbine he swings around in a
backflip and he lands upside down on the
ceiling
all this is to show that this is a
spider-man who doesn't exist in a vacuum
one who lucked into his powers by
accident his rise feels so powerful and
heroic because it's made up of moments
in which she was weak an answer to his
past failures but he learned from these
failures and he proved that he belongs
with the others and I just love that
Stanley again and again sneaks into this
movie because his wisdom was right from
the beginning when I was totally got
this but I want to know which of the
alternate spider people would you want
to see an entire movie set in comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on Twitter and Instagram add a vas and
come check out my monthly live comedy
show darkest timeline its subscribed to
this channel and subscribe to our
podcast where if you listen to podcasts
thank you for watching and let's see if
bagels and this universe sound the same
cool
[Music]